Why bother with this
strange we'll book at all.
And
that's a good question.
You know,
um,
it's a contradictory
document that's been cobbled
together over thousands of years.
It's outlasted kingdoms,
many,
many kingdoms.
You know,
it's,
it's really interesting that it turns
out that a book is more durable than,
than stone.
It's more durable than a castle.
It's more durable than an empire.
And that's really interesting.
You know,
that,
that it's something in some sense,
so evanescent can be so long living.
So there's that,
that's kind of a mystery.
I'm approaching this whole scenario.
This is the biblical stories as if
they're a mystery fundamentally be,
because they are,
there's a lot we don't
understand about them.
We don't understand how they came about.
We don't really understand
how they were put together.
We don't understand why they had such
an unbelievable impact on civilization.
We don't understand how people
could have believed them.
We don't understand what it means
that we don't believe them now or,
or even what it would mean
if we didn't believe them.
They're theirs.
And then on top of all that,
there's the additional problem,
which isn't specific to me,
but it's certainly relevant to me
that no matter how educated you are,
you're not educated enough to discuss
the psychological significance of the
biblical stories.
But I'm,
I'm going to do my best and partly
because I want to learn more about them.
And one of the things I've learned is
that the best way to learn about something
is to talk about it.
And when I'm lecturing,
I'm thinking,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not trying to tell you what
I know for sure to be the case,
because there's lots of things I
don't know for sure to be the case.
I'm trying to make sense out of this.
And I have been doing
this for a long time.